turning now to the economy the fed is
expecting to raise interest rates again
today in a bid to slow the inflation now
this could have a big big impact on the
cost of borrowing money for your home or
a car slower inflation is also a top
priority for the biden administration
caitlyn huey burns has more from
washington
today the federal reserve is at the
center of the fight to bring down
inflation overall prices for just about
everything have gone up 8.3 percent in
the past year groceries spiked more than
13 percent electricity by almost 16
percent rent nearly 7 percent so in the
hopes of bringing down prices central
bankers are expected to raise interest
rates by three quarters of a percentage
point the fifth rate hike this year
they're on the war path aggressively
raising rates president biden can't tame
inflation but he told 60 minutes he's
optimistic about getting it under
control we hope we can have it they say
a soft landing a transition
to a place where we don't lose the gains
that iran to make in the first place
that soft landing involves bringing
prices down without sparking such a big
slowdown that the economy slips into a
recession and the rate hikes will have
other direct impacts on americans when
it comes to borrowing the average credit
card interest rate is already at an
all-time high of more than 18 percent
and it could go even higher and when it
comes to buying a home rate hikes have
helped push a 30-year fixed mortgage
above 6 percent that's more than double
from a year ago and the highest in 14
years economist mark zandy says odds of
a recession are about 50 50. if we get a
little bit of luck we don't get hit with
another shock and we get some reasonably
good policy making by the fed we should
be able to make it through but those are
a lot of ifs
and there are concerns of course that
all of this could further rattle wall
street and with the midterms just seven
weeks away the economy remains the top
issue for voters nate
caitlin thank you